a time for leverage but sometimes it's
just violence it's just Brute Force most
people can't comprehend that someone is
doing 50 times more work than them
you're like why can't my CS grow or why
can't my arms grow and they're doing
arms three sets of biceps once a week
it's like well when I was trying to grow
my arms I was doing 10 sets 6 days a
week so I was doing 60 sets and they
were doing three so I was doing 20 times
the volume so literally if they train
for 20 weeks their way out of the same
volume in one week and so that's the
thing is people get really obsessed with
like Optimal which is just you get the
most bang for the buck but there's also
maximizing which is just getting the
most bucks